well let's jump to uh more American
domestic politics in relation to this we
have this from firstpost.com did the
weapons Hamas used against Israel come
from Ukraine or Afghanistan asks us
congresswoman margerie Taylor green says
we need to work with Israel to track
serial numbers on any Us weapons used by
Hamas against Israel did they come from
Afghanistan did they come from Ukraine
highly likely the answer is both I don't
completely disagree I mean I don't know
for sure what we need is evidence but we
have this from Jim Ferguson on Twitter
Jim Ferguson UK he is former
parliamentary candidate with the brexit
party in barnesley reporting breaking
news Israel Us weapons left behind in
Afghanistan used to attack Israel a
high-ranking Israel uh Israel Defense
Forces Commander said Us weapons left in
Afghanistan by the Biden administration
were found in the hands of Palestinian
groups active in the Gaza Strip the
chaos that erupted after the US
scrambled to evacuate Afghanistan as
ordered by Biden and the significant
amount of weapons and equipment left
behind there has now been used to attack
Israel a close Ally of the US Biden is
incapable of leadership and a total
embarrassment on the world stage I don't
know that any of this is confirmed right
we have this link I wonder if it works
this is uh amage news I don't know what
this source is take these things with a
grain of salt this is a story from June
18th 2023 weapons left by the US in
Afghanistan reach the hands of
Palestinian militants says Israel and
again this is from June so it may be the
case and I think it is fair to say
considering the Taliban desire to
support uh Gaza pal the Palestinians it
makes sense that the weapons that they
got got control over would would fall
into the hands of uh the
Palestinians now uh the bigger picture I
suppose is whether or not any of this is
true it as I me as I mentioned a moment
ago people when it comes to Israel
Palestine their brains shut off I'm I'm
sorry I'm not saying literally everyone
maybe not you guys but it's impossible
to have conversations with people about
this we've even had guests like I
mentioned who just l lose it and can't
hear reason their brains are just not
working the point is that being said
this will be tremendously bad for Joe
Biden when Afghanistan happened Joe
Biden lost something like 15 points in
the polls I imag Netanyahu cannot stand
the guy I imagine he finds no comfort in
uh Biden being around being in control
you want to call it uh obviously the
surrender of military equipment and
human life to the Taliban in Afghanistan
was one of those egregious losses of
American Military right I mean this this
theory is even on the table because
Biden handled Afghanistan so poorly
right we can't totally know for sure I
you know I I agree with Tim take it a
little with the grand assault but the
fact that we know weapons and other
supplies were left behind means that
this is on the table in the first place
which again is a direct responsibility
of the Biden Administration I I don't
understand how anyone can defend Biden
going into 2024 given the record and the
position that he has put everyone in in
the the last what two years of his
presidency but I don't like that
everyone is kind of jumping on the Biden
Administration and trying to blame
America for this conflict this conflict
has been going on for a long time to say
the least for sure for sure and everyone
wants to always attribute things to
America like oh they released the aid to
the uh sanctions on Iran so they got six
billion it's like that hasn't been
confirmed we don't know that Iran
directly directed this attack we don't
know that the funds were directly used
but what we're seeing are people like
Senator Lindsey Graham and the neocons
in the Republican Party trying to score
points against Biden and saying we need
to bomb Iran's oil refineries when we
don't even know what the facts are yet
we don't even know we don't know the
extent of this excuse someone pointed
that out about Lindsey Graham he's
almost 70 and has no kids so he has like
nothing to
lose he want hey look I'll tell you what
here for a long time he wants to put on
the cowboy hat and ride the atomic bomb
down and like uh what was that was that
Dr Str I actually visualized him going
to the front lines in his his fat body
he would not go Lindsay come on Lyn dude
what hey look man I'm I'm look I if you
tell me that you're in favor of uh
funding and support for any country no
matter what it is is Israel or Ukraine
hey man I got some uh military pts we
got some ammo we we we'll suit you up
we'll put you in basic training we'll
send you right off first light and when
I visualize him going he'd be like I'm
too old to go but it's okay for your
relatives and Sons and children to go
it's fine with him dude what the man
look you know more people is still
better right so if you're in favor of
going to war with any country like I got
to we we could suit you up you know what
I mean so the people who are all for
intervention in Ukraine it's like let's
suit you up buddy like I and and look a
lot of the people did go that's crazy
remember that guy from M what was that
MSNBC guy who went to Ukraine oh yeah
yeah who was that I don't remember who
was
Mal that fake video where he pointed and
didn't he pretend that there was like an
air strike or something when there was
no there was like there was like a you
heard a sound of a jet or something or
bombing and he goes he's like one two
bomb three bombings that's what's
happening it's like oh shut up dude yeah
thaty look man at least he went there I
guess reminds me of that movie Edge of
Tomorrow when they're like going to send
to cruise to the front line like and
Malcolm Nance you're going in but hey
look look I'm not saying that Israel is
right or wrong I'm just saying if you
want military funding for any of these
countries Lindsey Graham wants to bomb
bomb Iran bro I will put you in that
plane you can pull the lever let's get
you let's get you going buddy my point
is this they won't do it no no they want
you they want your kids to go die for
this yeah that's sick you know I think
this is not a war of Islam against
Judaism I think it's a war of it release
us from this open air prison no I don't
think it's a religious thing it's been
religious for dude that doesn't explain
it's always been for land it's always
been for land even though they Hezbollah
exists okay all right Iran has stated
they want to kill Jews they'll use it R
it is not about thinking about 911 which
is why I brought it up cuz they said
it's the it's the Muslims that want it
no we wanted the oil in the Middle East
so we went in and took it and we said
muslim Muslim and we caused all this
chaos and it was just like that was
stupid of me because now I'm I'm like I
want to I'm thinking like dude the worst
threat we could face is Islamic
terrorist it's not okay it is terrorism
in general but I think the Russians are
Christian I mean the Russians are like
Orthodox Christian they should be on our
side defending what's right you know
what's what's good and right I'm not
saying it's a but I don't want it to
turn into some religious thing just we
got to we got to call a white piece in
in Ukraine and start working together to
defend
Earth I mean I don't think Ukraine wants
to UK ukra and Russia have not uh
successfully worked out a Prest deal
I'll say that and I think it would be
impossible to say okay guys we've got a
new world conflict so you guys just take
a pause and we'll move on I mean what
I'm waiting for next is anything to
happen in Taiwan because everyone can
tell that we are on the brink of very
serious chaos and I think everyone knows
the US doesn't have strong leadership I
agree with your point we we can't blame
the Biden Administration for everything
there are lots of historical factors
going in I just know that in the last 3
years we have not positioned ourselves
the way I would like to be going into
this kind of conflict and there's a
question about whether the American the
leadership of the American federal
government uh is best serving the
American people I can't say
internationally what's going on we we
can blame the Biden Administration yeah
I mean look we can reduce any argument
we can go further and further back what
was the real cause of World War II World
War I what was the real cause of World
War I okay fine at a certain point we
talk about the the actions here under
Donald Trump Abraham Accords
normalization of relations between
Israel and many Arabic Nations Donald
Trump uh no new Wars and uh while there
was budding conflict with Ukraine and
Russia under Obama it stops when Trump
gets in weird Trump actually starts
investigating this uh uh this corruption
how strange Isis decimated the intention
of the existing Administration the unip
party in the country is to perpetuate
War for their neoliberal new world order
whatever you want to call it those are
their words not mine when they say the
what do they called the liberal World
Order and the liberal economic order or
the uh new world order again it was the
CFR that called it a new world order
whatever or I think they also call it
like the American liberal economic order
they they'll specify that it was an
American Le thing Trump's attitude is
like we're going to secure our borders
and bring manufacturing back and mind
their own business and everyone else was
like well okay that sounds good to us
and then Biden gets in and he's like
going to blow him up and now we've got
War everywhere just crazy so yeah I'm
sorry it's like at a certain point I'm
not going to go into the nitty-gritty of
all the classified documents to
determine was Russia biting their time
and it was just a coincidence that all
this happened the way it did and just be
like nah the simple answer is this under
Donald Trump no war under Joe Biden lots
of War I think it's Biden
administration's fault yeah and Trump
even had Bolton in Trum one point told
Putin that if he aggressed he would uh
Trump would nuke Moscow he told Shan
ping that as well and then he I think he
was like I don't know if he believed me
but it was F even if it was 5% that's
enough Trump said that and he's right
yeah it's it's any kind of doubt I mean
he was the one who cared No One Believes
that Biden could do the same thing and I
think I don't know I I don't want to I
know we're going to talk about uh RFK Jr
in a second but I just really think this
is one of the the moments that Democrats
are going to have to evaluate if they
can get behind the Biden Administration
for a second I think this this this this
might be it for him this is going to
destroy what the Biden his base is like
Pro Palestine I mean I I think so him
sending support to Israel immediately
you don't think the far left base no the
the average Democrat voter probably
doesn't know or care at all and might
just give you a generic but we support
Israel far- leftists will vote for Joe
Biden because they're crazy people and
but not all of them did but but a lot of
them did a lot of these prominent
leftists and antifa people who have big
social media followings endorsed Joe
Biden and said like we're we got to
support him because Trump's a fascist so
they did uh they they support Palestine
but but Joe Biden's actual voter B bace
which is the default liberal is probably
more align with
Israel the ignorant masses yeah the
ignorant masses all they hear is
Democrats saying like Israel's an ally
we must protect them and they go yeah
the far leftists are like Palestinians
you know from the river to Sea etc etc
and then you have conservatives who
understand quite a bit more and overtly
support Israel not all of them but a lot
of them and then you have Libertarians
who don't want us involved in any of it
that actually is not working for me
anymore I used to I used to start to
think along those lines of non- interven
interventionism but uh not anymore why
what changed um I I thought a lot about
World War II and if we hadn't gotten
involved in World War II what would have
happened Hitler would have taken over
the world I really don't think so I mean
he was about to he took he took France
in like three weeks taking over the
world is a very very bold and kind of
crazy statement considering I I he would
taken Europe he would taken Britain he
would have taken Europe he would have
taken Britain and he would have murdered
lots and lots of innocent people but the
world is a bit much you know right now
they're saying like Vladimir Putin is
going to take Poland I'm like oh shut up
come on no way come on not going to
happen no way you know they're like
they're saying like the Russian forces
are decimated and they're losing and
Ukraine's winning but he'll take
Poland dude I think I was saying was it
before the show I've been so accustomed
to false Flags just because golf of
tonen I was talking to my dad he was
like oh yeah that was he went he served
in Vietnam he was in the Navy and he
remembers the false so that I'm like so
anti- intervalent interventionalist but
uh then sometimes people just get
attacked sometimes your country gets
invaded and I've never lived that life
because I'm from the United States in
the late '90s you know where we never
got invaded But now sometimes it it just
sometimes it can happen and you got to
be realistic about that there's no time
to Waffle if your country is under
attack you can't let the a hot air
balloon float all the way across your
land mass like you split second decision
balloon that we did let float Across
America yeah it's asinine and Montana
was like wait there's something here and
we were just like who knows we'll just
see what happens oh wait we shot it down
later I mean I I get you know the desire
to sort of feel like you you need to act
right but in in this case you have to go
back to like our government is to serve
the American people and what is
ultimately the best interest of the
American people I can understand an
argument for we have allies we've made
agreements we've made deals but you know
I think the president has the duty to
the American people first and we can't
forget that thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net